for many black and white that flag was a  reminder of systemic oppression  and racial subjugation we see that now  removing the flag from this States  capital would not be an act of political  correctness it would not be an insult to  the Valor of Confederate soldiers it  would simply be an acknowledgement that  the cause for which they fought the  cause of slavery was wrong  the imposition of Jim Crow after the  Civil War the resistance to civil rights  for all people was wrong it would be one  step in honest accounting of America's  history a modest but meaningful bomb for  so many unhealed wounds it would be an  expression of the amazing changes that  have transformed this state and this  country for the better because of the  work of so many people of goodwill  people of all races striving to form a  more perfect union  yeah by taking down that flag we express  God's grace